and this is a world of trailers which is
funny because I upload my review of
incarnate people were like dude editing
my last of those two trailer people like
dude this is guardians of the galaxy to
talk about it so this guardians of the
galaxy trailer I guess it's like another
teaser it's like teaser number 2 which
isn't actually a full trailer you hear
rocket go in the fate of the universe
lies on your shoulder so whatever you do
don't push this button do you understand
a little baby Groot that baby Groot is
so cute little tears Bynes throws him
over alleged kills him he's like a
little shop of groups and yeah after
rocket saying don't push that button
baby Groot Slyke I am Groot kill
everybody don't push that I'll try again
the Greeks like I yes am yes Groot no
brute once you just push that button and
destroy everybody apart in this trailer
has a great point rockets like I want to
put tape over the death button does they
want to have tape star loads like you
have a nuclear weapon in your backpack
if he was gonna have tape it's gonna be
you I was like to shade anyone who had a
bomb or manufactured something of some
kind and was asking someone else for teh
tracks does have a great part at the
ends but before that he's yelling it's
always excuse like your literal right
you don't know sarcasm you're actually
telling who you're yelling at to screw
themselves literally this is a war cry a
call to arms for a dick to enter the
enemy I like your style Drax but at the
end his alien touch of star-lord she's
like when I touches someone I can feel
their I can see their thoughts like you
feel love he's like general love no
sexual look now for heard like totally
calls him out for Gamora the interaction
starts laughing his ass off and for this
figure I was like no that's like her
putting her hand on my arm going you
have an orange shirt on with a blazer
I'd be like yeah Captain Obvious I do
I also also want to have sex with Gamora
so you know it all works out okay I'm
sure guardians of the galaxy to who's
gonna have the fun Star Wars ish things
in this ship fights but that's not what
makes it cool it is the characters it's
the Croods the sarcasm it's rocket and
now baby Groot because what's cuter than
a little homicidal plant nothing again
not much to say about this trailer since
this trailer is another teaser trailer
and it shows
as much as the last Caesar trailer I
like the humor at the dracs moment I
love the fact that star-lord got called
out from wanting to bang Gamora we
shouldn't be too shocking because she
completely knows by now I'm just saying
that a romantic moment while she was
freezing to death in the depths of space
it's a no-shit kind of situation I mean
how the new guardians of the galaxy -
teaser trailer trailer - slash next
trailer that doesn't show much because
it's another teaser trailer have you
seen that what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]